[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant partons en rade de brest
oui souvenez-vous aux sables d'olonne
nous avons assisté au départ de vendée
globe et les rescapés continuent leur
tour du monde sur leur monocoque
pendant ce temps là d'autres navigateurs
se prépare un tour du monde façon jules
verne en 80 jours à concarneau
nous avions rencontré olivier de
kersauson il n'avait pas voulu mon nous
montrer son trimaran en construction et
le voilà qui navigue en rade de brest
les navigateurs adore la rade de brest
valérie heurtel a vu naviguer le charal
depuis quelques jours la curiosité du
port du moulin blanc c'est charal un
catamaran de 27 mètres de long qui se
prépare tout doucement à faire le tour
du monde en 80 jours
depuis une semaine charal est en période
d'essai sous la main experte d'un car
souvent tendues concentré mais confiant
dans son bateau c'est un bateau qu'on a
fait dans l'esprit de tout le monde
donc ya pas le même rapport de puissance
caution à 60 pieds comme et remo mais
c'est quand même un bateau
un bateau de glisser un grand bateau
c'est un bateau pour aller dans le sud
pourquoi on dit que cfoot partir pas
tour du monde sur un multicoque plus que
sur un monocoque est tout le monde dit
que les chaussons ceux-là en dit carrier
c'est fou ils ont 19 ans tu bois dans
lequel je vois c'est plus spéciales
restaient que un multicoque si on se
retrouve couché sur le côté quoi vont
servir on se relèvera par kyle elle
c'est pas le même pilotage pour faire
attention c'est satin conditions ça peut
être passé par bourg et le tour du monde
n'y a pas 36 manières on descend
l'atlantique on coupe l'équateur 1 200
on passe ou l'afrique du sud les îles
kerguelen entre entre tous qui a tout ce
qui reste de terre un hémisphère sud et
le continent antarctique en ayant les
siens d'aller assez près du continent
son actif parce que la route est plus
courte en même temps
en évitant le tout d'abord mystère guy
savoy cependant à la casse qui a eu
justement sur les bateaux sont partis
les ennuis causés ce qu'ils pensent je
commençais à m'angoisser pour les ennuis
les eaux je me sens très bien à dépasser
janvier à la partie du 15 janvier en
stand by
et pourquoi vous avez choisi partir de
brest alors que septième but
j'aime bien vrai ce noir plus bref c'est
un vrai point de départ s'est situé à
48,30 nord donc ça fait c'est l'entrée
de la manche c'est une rade abri
formidable c'est un poste d'attentes san
millan et puis j'aime bien brecht et que
je trouve ça plus plus élégant de partir
de chez nous pour rentrer chez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]